my daughter was uh
was having a dance thing at our school
they had this big dance
anyway we all went all the parents and
everybody's there and everybody's got
their phone
every single parent it was an amazing
thing to watch because kids are dancing
and every parent is standing there like
this every single person
was blocking their vision of their
actual child
with their phone and the kids i went
over by the stage and the kids there's
people holding ipads in front of their
faces
it looked like we're all in the witness
protection program like the kids
can't see their parents and everybody's
watching a
shitty movie of something that's
happening 10 feet like look at your
[ __ ] kid
the resolution on the kid is
unbelievable if you just
look that it's totally hd
why are you taping this you're never
gonna watch it
in a million years you're not gonna
watch videos of your kids
doing [ __ ] you missed the first time it
happened
you don't watch it you just put it on
facebook here you
watch it i wanna take a nap
now
and then you get to read all the
comments oh my god
it's so cute
and guess what they're not watching it
either they're not
watching the video these kids are
dancing for no one
nobody watches the videos on your
facebook they see the first frame of a
kid and they go ah that's very nice
okay back to this
[Applause]
nobody's watching your kids videos on
facebook i promise you i'll prove it to
you
next time you take your kids dance take
one second of it and then add
20 minutes of just your own [ __ ] just
go in the bathroom and just
record your own anus
opening and closing for 20 minutes
tack it on to your kid dancing for a
second put that on facebook
everybody will write the same thing
that's adorable
i think i see a future star
hey for the ninth consecutive year uh
nick jet blue air
airlines rank first for satisfaction
among all north american airlines
but you know what ranked least in
satisfaction
911 airlines what a terrible name for an
airline it reminds me of that tragedy
about 9 11. i don't laugh at 9 11.
i try to tell them not to laugh i know i
walked through blood and bones
in the streets of manhattan trying to
find my brother jesus yeah he was in
northern canada
so one time i'm flying into albany new
york okay
a city that nobody really goes to so i'm
on a smaller plane
and everything's going great all of a
sudden out of nowhere we hit this
turbulence
[Music]
right and it stops and everybody looks
around like laughing nervously like
all of a sudden it comes back with a
vengeance
you can literally hear like the metal
the planes man i'm like
all of a sudden this dude like three
rows back starts making like these
[ __ ] noises like
whoa whoa
[Applause]
i'm not gonna lie i have never been so
[ __ ]
scared in my entire life
do that noise is acceptable out of a
female
or a child to turn around
and see a 37 year old mustachioed male
going
dude the hair was standing up on my arms
i'm praying to a higher power i don't
even believe in the [ __ ]
i just wish i had the balls to turn
around and be like dude would you shut
the [ __ ] up
jesus christ be a man push it down push
it down deny your feelings
act like you have answers do some man
[ __ ] right now
do some man [ __ ]
jesus christ you know
you think i'm not up here thinking i am
but how does that help us for me to join
you and turn this fuselage into a
haunted house
you know you know what kills me
what absolutely kills me is some woman
is going to fall in love with this guy
marry him and make half [ __ ] kids
and you know what we become weaker as a
species
we do
you know like a lot of people will be
telling me dave you know you just gotta
relax the racism thing we bugging you
too much
i'll be thinking about it sometimes [ __ ]
don't happen a lot of black people can
relate to this have you ever had
something happen that was so racist
that you didn't even get mad he was just
like god damn that was right that was
racist
i mean it was so blatant he was just
like wow
like he almost like it didn't even
happen it was like a [ __ ] movie
that was like he was watching
mississippi burning wow
that happened to me i was in mississippi
i was in mississippi doing a show
and i go to the restaurant to order some
food and
uh i say to the guy i said i would like
to have
and before i even finish my sins he says
the chicken
i could not believe it could not believe
that [ __ ]
this man was absolutely right i said how
did he know
that i was going to get some chicken
i asked him how you know that how did
you know i was gonna get some chicken
he looked at me like i was crazy come on
buddy come on buddy
now everybody knew soon as you walk
through the goddamn door
you're gonna get some [ __ ] there's no
secret down here that blacks
and chickens are quite fond of one
another
[Applause]
then i finally understood what he was
saying and i got upset
i wasn't even mad i was just upset i
wasn't
ready to hear that [ __ ]
all these years i thought i liked
chicken because it was delicious
turns out i'm genetically predisposed to
liking chicken
i said why
i got no say in the man i got ruined
chicken for me i'm scared to eat it in
public i don't
i want somebody to see me and say
something i mean like eating some
chicken
look at him he loves it
just like it's in the encyclopedia look
how happy he looks
sometimes it will be too much to deal
with and show business be crazy that's
where the cultures
really collide show business bring a lot
of races together
sometimes it works sometimes i don't
this is one thing that happens it's
funny
you know sometimes i'll be on a business
call right you know like with a with a
lawyer or something you know my lawyers
be white
and uh and
like we'll be on a call right and
they'll be like
oh okay dave we're gonna we're gonna
close the deal was that fine with you
i'll be like yeah that's good for me
great great you have a good weekend dave
i'll be like all right you too man
peace all right bye bye
they don't know what to say right so
sometimes like
sometimes i'll make up [ __ ] that's not
even slain
just to see how they handled it it'd be
the same business go
all right we're gonna close the deal is
that fine with you dave yeah sounds good
to me great
you have a good weekend dave all right
buddy zip it
up and zip it out
oh all right so we do now bye